thousands have come to witness this
event German demolition experts are
about to detonate the explosives to
level a former cement mill several days
earlier they prepared the explosives a
stick of dynamite costs only a few euros
Michel hick had to cut 1,500 individual
portions it is the consistency of
marzipan you can cut it with a kitchen
knife but you need to work on a wooden
board so there is no risk of striking
sparks box by box the demolitions
experts amass 250 kilograms of the
explosives they need to blow up the mill
it consists of 480 meter high towers
built from extremely robust reinforced
concrete
they can't risk the tiniest mistake the
mill is located near the center of
Vettes la a town in the middle of
Germany the buildings there are
historically listed
the demolitions experts are part of an
experienced team used to working with
one another there's little risk in
handling the dynamite now it will
explode
only if triggered by a small detonation
this detonator contains a delay charge
and a small amount of explosives the
explosives create a shock wave that
triggers the dynamite on alpha inch bang
stuff on toddlers with the making stuff
don't give up the demolitions experts
spent four weeks planning the detonation
they calculated where every portion of
dynamite should be placed to control how
the towers will fall for these former
employees this used to be their
workplace but Heidelberg cement gave up
the mill now a Swedish furniture chain
plans to open a store here it's a shame
the cement mill was in operation for
over 100 years he used to run 24 hours a
day divided into four shifts
you couldn't just turn off the oven 70
people used to work in the mill the
factory buildings have already been
demolished all that's left are the four
towers between them layers of fine
rubble are piled up when the towers fall
that'll cushion the impact and reduce
tremors
édouard wife who runs the demolition
company will earn a six-figure sum for
leveling the tars now he and his
colleagues are wiring up the dynamite
heist and his hobby into his career as a
kid I was fascinated by fireworks and
then by homemade explosives
I can only warn against making those
it's been 30 years since I developed
this passion and it still excites me the
only difference is that over time the
things i detonate have become larger the
explosives will be detonated when night
falls beforehand the experts check all
the wires again the tension Rises the
demolition requires a succession of
1,500 demolition charges each time to
the millisecond you have to imagine that
the detonator in the form that is
delivered to us doesn't know what it's
supposed to do only when we hook it up
to this logger can we program it to go
off at a certain time the whole town is
up to witness the spectacle
this is a unique event it's not to be
missed
this is the end of an era
time to take cover
the towers form just as planned
the demolition is a success the experts
are relieved textbook demolition this
expansive rubble means a job well done
demolishing the old means making room
for the new